good morning believe nation today's
message is love who you are over to you
Quincy Jones know who you are and
learning to love who you are as you
can't love anybody else if you don't
love yourself ray or not Charles Maggie
used to say every day in Seattle not one
drop of myself work depends on your
acceptance of me every day that was the
deal with racism with everything because
you don't want an external force
defining who the hell you are not one
ounce of my self-worth depends on your
acceptance of me I love that sentence I
had to rewind and play it back a couple
times kind of sends chills and I think
too many people don't feel that way
earlier this week I went to an event
with the mayor of Toronto we were
talking about how Toronto could be a
better city for entrepreneurs and I was
invited to be on the panel with him in
three other entrepreneurs and I went
with my entrepreneur t-shirt on of ant
City with the seeing tower on it I went
wearing track pants and my five toe
shoes and with a huge Frappuccino in my
hand and that's how I sat on the panel
and you know the mayor's in a suit
everybody you know came out had various
degrees of formality in their wear and
and there was a little bit of a surprise
that I was sitting on stage wearing what
I was wearing at least of the people who
didn't know me and I didn't care like
for me I know I'm gonna provide value I
know I'm gonna rock it I don't I don't
want to go out and wear a suit to try to
live up with somebody else's
expectations what they think about me
doesn't change how I'm going to act and
I know I'm going to provide amazing
value and I did and part of that comes
down to just me having confidence in
myself and loving myself and that took
time to build up another quick story
from that same day I rarely prepare now
for questions I used to be the guy who
prepared questions when they sent me
them and always have to know what the
questions what they want to ask me I
always want to have my
accident figures down and be super
prepared and by the time I got on camera
it was such a rehearsed answer I know
certain nervous delivering it because I
was worried how they would judge me that
it was never a fantastic answer may be
in factually correct but didn't have any
passion didn't have any emotion didn't
move people as I get more confidence to
myself as I love myself more I learned
to be more spontaneous and it was super
scary at the start but I learned to be
more spontaneous and now I'm at the
point where I don't want to see your
questions I'd rather have it be a live
discussion because my first answer is
gonna be the one with the most passion
the more I think about it the more
factor its gonna get the more I might
worry about it and then the more I
practice it it's not gonna be as quality
a delivery so I was talking to Alex on
Monday about the questions that I was
going to get asked for the mayor event
and the reason why I don't look at the
questions now is because I also feel
like I can provide value to any question
I'm gonna be able to answer the question
I mean if we given the facts and figures
that they're looking for but I believe
that I can add value to any question and
I walk into every interview you know
every every session any panel any
conference any event feeling like
whatever question gets thrown at me I
can add value I'll be able to either
answer that question or answer the
question they should have asked and so
it comes down to when you love yourself
when you have that confidence you're
able to be the best version of yourself
you're able to continue to push yourself
and as long as you don't rely on other
people to get your self-worth that'll
help you continue to chase your dreams
and continue to be that best version of
yourself instead of trying to live up to
other people's expectations in
minimizing yourself so the question of
the day today is do you really love who
you are going deep today leave in the
comments below I'm gonna join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
Peevy